it's been a violent holiday weekend in
chicago where shootings have killed at
least four people and wounded more than
40 others police blame some of the
violence on illegal guns bought in other
states and they're starting to crack
down on it as charlie damar of our
chicago station wbbm tv reports victims
of gun violence say it's about time
there have been more than 2 300
shootings in chicago so far this year
michelle chambers 28 year old son was
one of the victims
five guns found at the scene were traced
back to this kentucky army base
prosecutors say three fort campbell
soldiers bought the guns legally but
were charged with selling them illegally
in chicago they're called shop purchases
in illegal practice in which a purchaser
is actually buying the gun on behalf of
someone else
and they fuel violence across the
country
last month nine people were charged in
an illegal gun pipeline that stretched
from new york to atlanta in minneapolis
investigators say three people bought
nearly 50 guns in an elaborate straw
purchasing scheme and in california a
licensed gun store owner was arrested
for using the names of police officers
to sell guns off the books
last month prosecutors say a gun from a
straw purchase was used to kill
29-year-old ella french the first female
chicago police officer murdered in the
line of duty in more than three decades
john lausch is the u.s attorney here
it's a legal product a firearm when they
end up illegally in someone else's hands
that's where we come in as law
enforcement earlier this summer attorney
general merrick garland announced the
justice department was creating strike
forces in five cities to target gun
trafficking kristin ditinio runs the
chicago atf office it is a major
cornerstone of our trafficking strategy
to identify those purchasers crime data
analyst jeff asher studies why gun crime
is spiking and where the weapons are
coming from but he says it's hard to get
a clear picture because of a federal law
that prevents gun trace data from being
released to the public you're relying on
anecdote rather than on actual data and
i think that makes it very difficult to
solve it lausch says in the end it's the
people who pull the trigger who are most
responsible our offenders are completely
emboldened they're not afraid of getting
caught they're not afraid of the
consequences once they get caught
crackdowns on gun crimes aren't new they
date back to at least the reagan
administration but with the body count
soaring the hope here is this time there
will be a real impact charlie damar cbs
news chicago